welcome back everyone it's Charlie these
are gonna be all my Joker movie Easter
eggs and Batman references there were 10
of Batman comic book Easter eggs
previous Batman films reference previous
versions of the Joker and other non
comic book films we're doing a giveaway
for movie tickets all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Joker moment please do use
spoiler tags for at least the next week
or so because there's still people that
haven't seen the movie yet
and obviously spoiler warning for
everything that happens in the movie
because we'll be talking about very
specific plot points first big Easter
Egg starts with the Warner Brothers logo
at the beginning of the movie is the
same logo from Superman 2 with
Christopher Reeve that's because that
was the standard Warner Brothers logo
for all Warner Brothers movies between
1972 and 1984 is the very first
indicator of when the movie is supposed
to take place even though they never
actually tell you what the exact year is
during the movie but what they do have
is a couple movie release Easter eggs at
the end of the movie like Zorro the gay
blade wolfin Excalibur the Arthur movie
those were all 1981 movie releases so we
can say it's probably taking place
during 1981 the Sanitation strike that's
going on in Gotham is a reference to the
Sanitation strikes in real life New York
City history through the 70s and 80s and
the New York City fiscal crisis of the
70s
Joker's real name Arthur Fleck is not a
comic-book reference Todd Phillips said
that he picked it because it sounded
like speck or flake making the Joker as
a character seem more insignificant as a
person the social worker he speaks to
during the movie is named Deborah Kane
in honor of Batman co-creator Bob Kane
the bank where Sophie his imaginary
girlfriend works is on William Street
that's a reference to Bill Finger other
Batman co-creator later we see a subway
stop at Robinson Park another reference
to former Batman artist Jerry Robinson
Joker lives in apartment 8 jj4 Joker in
8 because he's the 8th big movie version
of the Joker Joaquin Phoenix's iconic
Joker lap is actually an affliction that
he develops as a result of childhood
abuse and head trauma comic book Joker
gets his iconic laugh after he falls
into the VAT of chemicals and Batman The
Killing Joke undergoing his physical and
psychological transformation there's a
more literal Killing Joke Easter Egg
when he go
to the Charlie Chaplin modern times
screening the camera lingers on the
protesters holding up signs one of the
signs says Killing Joke in speaking of
that Batman's story Arthur in the movie
is also an aspiring comedian just like
Joker was during Killing Joke
there are also two other Joker stories
that reference his early comedic
ambitions before he became the Joker
there was a tie-in comic book that they
made for the Batman 1989 film with
Michael Keaton in Jack Nicholson called
the further adventures of Joker
anthology published in 1990 which
features Jack Nicholson's Jack Napier
character spending his early life
scrawling jokes in notebooks just like
Arthur does during the movie there was
also an episode of batman the animated
series called laughing up where they did
a version of Killing Joke origin story
showing Joker trying and failing to
become a stand-up comedian before he
became the Joker
[Laughter]
[Music]
different hair the Joker the stand-up
comedy club that he goes to for practice
is called pogos which is named after
Pogo the clown the alias used by John
Wayne Gacy Arthur's relationship with
his deranged mother is a reference to
Norman Bates relationship with his
mother in the movie psycho and even
though I don't totally buy that she was
telling the truth about Arthur being
Thomas Wayans son on the back of her
picture Thomas Waynes message to her
reads love your smile TW a reference to
the Joker's smile then a very big Heath
Ledger Batman Dark Knight Joker
reference at the end of the film when
he's painting the smile on his face in
blood you want to know how I got these
scars the actor Bret Cohen in real life
who plays Thomas Wayne says that it's
his opinion that Thomas Wayne drove
penny crazy 30 years ago and is
responsible for her being put in Arkham
Asylum but that's not the opinion of
Todd Phillips the writer and director of
the movie as for whether or not Joker is
actually Thomas Wayne's son in the film
Todd Phillips only said that he wrote it
that way to make Joker believe that he
was Thomas Wayne's son is a way to give
him a compelling reason for hating
Batman so much later when Batman would
eventually become Batman
he didn't say that penny was telling the
truth Phillips only said that he wanted
Joker to believe that it was the truth
not that it was the actual truth but
there is an actual canonical comic book
version of Joker that is Thomas Wayne's
son and that is the Batman who laughs
because the Batman who laughs is a
version of Bruce Wayne from the dark
multiverse who turned into a version of
the Joker Joker goes on a date with the
fake version of Sophie that he
hallucinates but the date takes place on
Jerome Avenue the character Jerome
Valeska on the Gotham TV show turned
into the Joker the crazy dance that the
Joker does inside the bathroom is a
reference to a Grant Morrison Batman
story Batman number 663 the clown
@midnight in it the dance is meant to be
a metaphor for him undergoing a
transformation emerging from a cocoon
like a chrysalis as his arms unfurl like
he's evolving from a caterpillar into
the butterfly Joker Joker confessing to
his crimes on the Murray Franklin TV
show on LY Beier is both a reference to
the Zodiac movie with the Zodiac killer
calling in live to confess
and then Joker killing Murray on live TV
is a reference to Batman The Dark Knight
Returns part 2 where the Joker kills an
entire live studio audience
on TV
[Applause]
[Music]
Joker you've asked for a chance to share
your side of things I'm told you've
killed about 600 people how exactly does
your side of that go that's why I'm
gonna kill everyone in this room more
fun Batman the Animated Series Easter
eggs the font that Murray Franklin's TV
show uses is also the same as the title
font from Batman the Animated Series
earlier in the film when Joker goes to
Wayne Manor and meets Bruce Wayne Bruce
slides down the pole in his tree house
just like 1966 Adam West's Batman
[Music]
we also wound up meeting the younger
version of Alfred during that encounter
but obviously at the end of the movie
the Wayne's are killed outside the
theater in Crime Alley the movies are
all Easter eggs for Batman's origin in
the comics and other Batman movie origin
stories Zora the gay blade is just an
updated version of the Mark of Zorro
from the original version of his origin
story in the 1940s it's just that that
was the version of Zorro playing at that
time and the newer version of Zorro was
playing in 1981 when this movie is
supposed to take place Excalibur is also
a reference to the Batman V Superman
opening scene and of course Joe Chill
wearing a clown mask killing Thomas
Wayne and Martha Wayne in front of Bruce
Wayne giving us our classic Batman
origin story reference they even do the
shot of the pearls flying off the fact
that he's wearing the clown mask is also
a wink at the Tim Burton Batman origin
story where it was the Joker himself
Jack Napier who committed the act
instead of comic book Joe Chill have you
ever danced with the devil in the pale
moonlight you could try to draw
references between Batman V Superman and
Ben Affleck's version of Batman in this
young version of Bruce Wayne the
timeline would line up for those
versions a lot of people wondering how
this is tied to the new Batman trilogy
that's coming up with Matt Reeves and
Robert Pattinson because that's supposed
to take place during the 90s the only
way that would work out is if that movie
takes place in the late 90s because this
version of Bruce Wayne looks like he's
barely ten years old but of course Todd
Phillips was asked this very specific
question if this version of the Joker
franchise would ever crossover with Matt
Reeves Batman trilogy and his answer was
basically no Robert Pattinson was just
cast as Batman I know this is a totally
different movie but but do you see those
two worlds merging together anytime soon
no most of you also probably noticed the
liberal Easter eggs for Martin
Scorsese's taxi driver in the king of
comedy jokers origin story from Arthur -
Joker follows a very similar path to
Travis bickel's story during taxi driver
as well as Robert De Niro's main
character from the king of comedy who
seeks to gain recognition and fame
through
terrible axe the Joker in the movie is
looking for people to notice him people
are finally starting to notice me there
were a lot of visual and story
references to both of those movies -
like when Travis Bickle is sort of
playing with the gun dancing around with
his shirt off the Joker is dancing
around accidentally setting the gun off
sorry mom it was just an old war movie
that I was watching there's also the
very notable Charlie Chaplin easter-egg
modern times is playing during the movie
at Wayne Hall Joker goes to try and
confront Thomas Wayne about his
parentage the plot of Charlie Chaplin's
modern times movie is all about the
plight of the working man during the
Great Depression it's all about class
struggle in class struggle is a big
theme of the Joker movie wall the clown
mask riots are happening outside the
theater that's why they focus so much on
the visual differences between the riots
and the streets and how crazy dirty and
awful everything looks - when he steps
inside the theater and it's almost like
he's stepping into a palace as far as
sequels go Joaquin Phoenix hasn't really
said anything about him coming back to
do anymore
I'm sure the movies already broken a
couple of October records it's smashed
venoms October record which is a new
all-time record for highest earning
October movie release but as I've said
in previous Joker movie videos that I've
done my most likely assumption is that
they'll just try to do another DC Black
Label film with another villain
character or another Batman comic book
character just a really focus smaller
film based on a single character so you
get a Riddler movie or maybe they would
try to do a war of jokes and riddles
movie where it's basically a Joker
versus The Riddler movie with a little
bit of Batman stuff in it but he's not
the main character it's just about the
Joker going to war with the Riddler or
they do a DC Black Label film about the
penguin or Rachel Ghul any of his iconic
comic book villains so if you spotted
any big Easter eggs during the movie
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments let me
know if there are any big questions that
you have about the film well obviously
everyone's still going to be talking
about what's real and what's fake about
that ending I've already done a video
about the ending of the movie I'll
include a link to that at the end of
this and in the description
congratulations JC for your the giveaway
winner from my last big Joker video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my Joker ending
scene video and click here for my Joker
review thank you
so much for watching everybody put on a
happy face I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]